humm read my spirit path
welcome to rope feminine presents
Lakeview cabin
it's been very highly praised I have no
idea exactly what to expect I know
there's a few jumps in it which I know
you both like and I know there's a
beautiful man with a mustache so what
else is would you need honestly let us
grab our shotgun pick up or drop items
oh [ __ ] okay nice that's me and my girl
I don't know why I went to sleep so
awkward dudes all right let's bring this
outside take that nature take this
nature how do I use it doesn't work
piece of [ __ ] take that I should pick
this up there you go all right
chop mmm chop what did I get glasses
gotta say the controls are a little
confusing
oh they're binoculars my bad what do we
see of it what is this game don't look
that is weird man I wonder if this is an
easter egg or an actual something what
happens if I go no I can't
the hell [ __ ] hey I'm not complaining
okay there's a key up there I'm taking
it nice butt crack trying to make sure
Edgar doesn't pull out the power cable
like last time okay let's use these acts
on this tree nope
see what's over here hey nature no come
back
what's up with this game [ __ ] weird
man okay nice like he matches his
carpets what there [ __ ] another one of
these let's see what's inside let's take
this to the toilet put it down
then we know stop taking a crap the
naked ginger man on its quest to find
naked ladies I'll know how to find that
naked lady Easter egg ride away whoa
what did I do
I didn't mean to do that Wow why is it
night anyway
Oh Oh what well that's depressing
I guess what a beer Trappe awesome I
don't know why I did that all right we
gotta be at right we should place it
here innit yes
Oh God let's throw the ax on that thing
I don't want to die there we go
all right we take it up we take it up
and then we are knit we are they to kill
how do I army oh that's [ __ ] man
how about we drink ah come on now the
controls are inverted god damn it why
did I do that
being a hillbilly rocks I'm surprisingly
enjoying this game I had no idea what to
expect that this is this [ __ ] weird
how do I arm the trap I don't yes okay
how do I get to the other side [ __ ]
that's a problem
Yolo ah dude that does not look good all
right oh I'm leaking blood that's normal
oh nice there we go all right now let's
get our flashlights now let's get our
flashlights go [ __ ] your ass is mine
[ __ ] tell me you like this tell
me you like this or what I knew you
liked it all right I know what you were
gonna do the naked ginger man has come
to destroy hey tell me you liked it
never
[ __ ] hell yeah gotta show him who's
boss what did he drop what was the point
of killing him now god damn it what if
we put some logs inside the fireplace oh
okay that works
cool
[Music]
please I'm riding a car what do you
watch my Bey battle have a bucket take
the bucket take the flattened all right
I'm taking a [ __ ] go sound real ghost
Andreea what the hell
what's rinconete know what triggered
that [ __ ] summoner oh oh oh next time
will be prepared by the [ __ ] this game
it's weird man
ah what the [ __ ] cannot again my
moustache [ __ ] come at me brah
come at me ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba [ __ ] dead
and I walk in the park of them retry I
choose you'll pick at you
alright come at me ah son of a bee sting
alright come at me [ __ ] oh god shut
disgust right no no no I choose you'll
pick a chill let me get my ax to confirm
the kill I'm not the stupid idiot like
those other people in our own video
movies [ __ ]
[Music]
get the shotgun don't come near me
that sounds real what are you doing just
telling that you idiot
[ __ ] I might as well get drunk you know
I might as well get [ __ ] naked yes
bucket how you will have sex I'm
bleeding from my anus go pick a chill
[ __ ]
wah wah die just wanna see boobs Yolo
she can come here right stupid Pokemon
scared of water
yeah shut didn't one of it alright don't
worry I have a plan
don't worry take it
[ __ ] die die die die I'm not it's over
there's only one kill it there ah decide
me [ __ ]
I have a mustache what are you gonna do
about it
do you see this moose no you see these
moves [ __ ] didn't think so
ah [ __ ] it's not come at me bro
cannot you da da [ __ ] that thing man
ah why me the hell am I supposed to do
that's fine Oh
ah it's so fast last chance fine Jess Oh
Jess gosh at how do i I can't shoot with
it because it has no [ __ ] bullets of
course so I'm hoping this flashlight is
gonna prevent something but I doubt it
well no not working no not even one
[ __ ] you pregnant [ __ ] i chopping wood
as I chop your womb but get it alright
now we play the waiting game
alright just don't miss click don't
panic and miss click you press X right
[Music]
I thought that would work why not but
what I can pick it up stop dancing on my
adventure no I don't want any one of you
[Music]
is going on [ __ ] [ __ ]
no stop dancing on my head ah you
[ __ ] feet no no no no no no I don't
wanna die now
ok alright alright drop it
No what am I supposed to do with you I
hope you hate water
[Music]
[Applause]
so smart now what the [ __ ] do we do with
the bees I don't [ __ ] know your back
just give up come back that come back
the hell are we supposed to did with the
bees no well I'm running out of [ __ ]
ideas god I hate you
game I'm sorry I couldn't finish it I
really [ __ ] tried but I couldn't
as I suck but maybe that will make it
even more fun for your bris to try it
out yourself I'll live it looking
description maybe like me enjoyed
watching I know it's a little different
but I think it was fun anyway
if this guy gonna birth today I'll see
you in the next one somebody mark let me
write it I got it I'm riding him
[Music]